firebase security when you build a
firebase app you can perform user
authentication
and work with your database entirely
from your front-end code
but how is this possible if our database
is exposed on the client wouldn't that
mean that any hacker could then read or
write private user data
the answer is no because your
infrastructure is protected by a
mechanism known as firebase security
rules which can be applied to real-time
database
cloud storage and firestore in a
traditional web application you have a
server
on that server you implement security
logic that uses either tokens or cookies
to verify that a user making a request
is authorized to do so firebase rules
achieve the same thing but without the
need to write maintain and deploy
server-side code
instead you create a policy to define
who has access to what
in your database using a very easy to
learn language called common expression
language
whenever a user makes a request to read
or write to your database that request
is routed through this policy
every operation is denied by default
when a request comes in
it will look for the first rule to allow
it once allowed firebase can then
securely read or write to your database
you can write rules from the firebase
console or your ide in the console
you can time travel back to any previous
rules you've used in the past or use the
playground to send a mock request to
your database
and in production you can analyze
exactly how your rules are being
executed
to enforce a rule we start by matching a
path in the database
which can be as broad as the entire
database or as granular as a single
document
a single document can be matched with a
collection followed by a document id
if we want anybody to read and write to
this document we can say allow read and
write
but that's not very secure let's make
sure a user is logged into our app to
view the document
which we can do by writing conditional
logic we allow the operation
if the request auth object does not
equal null when it comes to writes we
can make sure
only the user that owns the document can
write to it by checking the request
auth user id in most cases though you'll
want your rules to apply to an entire
collection
if we wrap the document id in braces the
rule now applies to any document in that
collection and we can use the document
id
as a variable in our logic and now we
have a firebase app that's 100 secure
without any vulnerabilities whatsoever
but there's a lot more to learn consider
becoming a pro member at fireship io to
get access to the new firebase security
master course where you'll learn all
kinds of advanced techniques for
real-world applications
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one